this week on brian ross investigates
showdown with a billionaire jeff bezos
has worked hard to keep unions
out of the company he founded and that
has made him rich
but now organizers at an amazon facility
in alabama are making the biggest push
yet
to unionize it doesn't matter how much
amazon is paying then
they don't treat them with respect if
they don't
acknowledge their humanity amazon pays
more than 15
an hour to its warehouse workers but
many say the working conditions
are harsh and stressful it's tough no
one wants to come to work and be treated
like a machine gun
treated like they're nothing plus rock
groups and movie stars
all have their fan clubs and so do
convicted murderers
like todd mullis the iowa farmer found
guilty of killing his wife
he couldn't have killed her he just he's
not that type of person
we'll meet the woman who formed the
facebook group to support mullis and try
to prove him innocent
i will admit i had a little crush at the
beginning why does she do it
and this week's winners and losers in
the media
see if you agree with the choices made
by the editors of mediaite
from the law and crime trial network
this
is bryan ross investigates
good evening and thank you for joining
us and welcome to our viewers on
facebook live i'm brian ross joined by
my colleague
rhonda schwartz at law and crime and
rhonda we begin with the showdown with a
millionaire
jeff bezos is one of the richest men in
the world and he recently stepped down
as the ceo of amazon
but he still is the central figure in an
effort by a union a major union
to unionize employees at an amazon
facility in alabama
if they are successful it could have
major implications for the huge company
rhonda
there are 5 800 workers at the huge
amazon warehouse in alabama
who are voting this week on whether to
join a union
and if they vote yes there could be big
ramifications for amazon's operations
around the country
and a big victory for the retail
wholesale and department store union
that started it all brian
amazon is proud of the system it has
created to deliver
so much so quickly to so many americans
at amazon we're pretty good at getting
things done
it's the talk of the business community
amazon acquired its undisputed status as
the heavyweight champion of the retail
universe
thanks largely to its lightning fast
delivery times but some workers at its
so-called
fulfillment centers including this one
in alabama
say that the amazing distribution system
has come at a huge price for amazon
workers
who complain of harsh conditions and
unrelenting deadlines
efforts to unionize the workforce in
alabama are underway
with workers voting over the next few
weeks about whether to join
the retail wholesale and departments to
our union
we're joined now by two employees at
that amazon facility in alabama
jennifer and ireland both of whom have
been connected with us uh through the
union
thank you both for being here jennifer
you were telling me before we began that
you actually are in
physical pain working your ten hour
shifts there
yes i am what's up what's it like
it's it's it's tough especially when
it's time to go to break and
you're thinking about should i take the
chance of walking out or should i just
stay where i am
and earl then do you feel the same sort
of thing are there physical pressures as
well as a mental stress in the job there
i do i really do um
as far as climbing the stairs sometimes
um
the repetitive movement and things of
that nature um
yeah so some jobs and you have to do the
repetitive movement but
you know to be like a robot so to speak
treated like a number instead of a
person um no one wants to come to work
and be treated like a machine and
treat it like they're nothing and
ireland finally let me ask you this
if it's so bad why not just quit and
find another job
um easier said than done
with the economy been how it is and with
the pandemic
you know jobs are smelling none um and i
really do feel like
um their amazon has potential to be a
better company than it is now uh
with the with the right
with the right leadership amazon says it
pays all of its workers
at least fifteen dollars an hour and
provides career opportunities
and that workers already get generous
benefits and health care
without a union and now the company has
started a national media campaign with
television ads
proclaiming what a fine company it is i
love that everybody is helpful here
work friends turn into work family and
how well
its workers are treated to all of our
amazon retail heroes
we'll continue to do everything we can
to keep you healthy
safe and protected we're joined now by
stuart alperbaum who's the president of
the retail wholesale
and department store union mr applebaum
thank you for being here
amazon says it pays more than the
minimum wage it pays more than 15
an hour and provides all the benefits
that your workers would get if they were
in your union
people say to us all the time
that it doesn't matter how much amazon
is paying them if they don't treat them
with respect
if they don't acknowledge their humanity
and that is why there is such an
enormous
turnover at amazon's facilities
it doesn't matter what they are being
paid
if amazon keeps on treating them the way
they do and by that what do you mean
well people feel dehumanized
and mistreated people are
people get their assignments from a
robot
they're disciplined uh by an app on
their phone
they're fired by a text message
they're forced to work at a pace that is
unsustainable
people get injured in amazon facilities
people
are getting sick and dying even before
the pandemic
jeff bezos was one of his uh core
principles as he
took over and built amazon into the
behemoth that it is
has always opposed unions how hard are
they fighting you now
amazon is conducting one of the most
aggressive
anti-union campaigns we have ever
seen they're bombarding people with
but um anti-union propaganda that even
when you go
to the bathroom in the bathroom stalls
they have anti-union messages posted at
eye level if you're sitting up a toilet
that's how expensive their campaign is
it's just this one facility in alabama
why is amazon fighting so hard
over that one facility and should you
win there and you certify the union what
are the implications of that
well i i think we have to look at the
implications
amazon understands that this is the
first
time ever that there has been an
election at one of their
fulfillment centers for the entire
workforce
if the workers prevail
and the union is certified
that is going to start
an organizing effort at not just
amazon facilities all over the country
but it's going to start
it's going to ignite an organizing
movement
at companies all across this country
i mean what really bothers me
is that our message is a simple one
we are saying that amazon can do better
by its employees and jeff bezos
is privileged enough to be in a position
where he is able to do better
and we do not understand why he doesn't
all right stupider applebaum thank you
so much for joining the president of the
retail
wholesale and department store union
thank you for being here tonight
thank you for having me we asked amazon
to provide a spokesperson to appear in
our program
but they declined coming up a convicted
killer
in iowa and the support group he has on
facebook
why do they do it you're watching brian
ross investigates on the law and crime
trial network
rock stars movie stars professional
athletes all have their fan clubs but so
do
accused and convicted killers as ronda
and i discovered as we put together a
10-part series by law and crime
for the a e network on killer cases
this thursday at 10 o'clock in a e will
profile the case of todd mullis an iowa
farmer who is convicted of killing his
wife
he has now got a large group of
supporters more than 600 people
who maintain he is innocent rhonda
that's right todd mullis is an iowa
farmer who's accused of killing his wife
on the farm with a pitchfork
but he has a large group of online
followers who believe he was wrongly
convicted
and he maintains his innocence it's a
fascinating case brian
in an odd but chilling new case out of
iowa todd mullis is accused of murdering
his wife
amy with a corn rape
it was very difficult to buy that story
amy was quite unhappy and was
actually thinking about leaving todd
there were aspects of an affair you
believe
the last time you saw her that you did
have some type of sexual relation we
started watching the first day and i was
hooked todd mullis looking at a big
penalty if he's convicted you know the
case kind of
took off it was compelling he killed him
he killed him now i can understand why
and could not believe that this man was
being tried for this
he couldn't have killed her there's a
search for
what did ancient cultures do to
infidelity did you do that serge
no 16 facts about cheating women did you
do that serge
no todd did you ambush
your wife amy in that shed that day and
brutally beat her and chop
chop her up with that corn fork no i did
not
you know who did i have no idea
we're joined now by tracy de ritter who
lives in upstate new york nowhere near
iowa but has formed a facebook group
todd bullis is innocent with some 600
people online
all in support of todd mullis tracy
thanks for being here
looking forward to seeing you on the
program this thursday night but why do
you do it
thanks for having me back brian um
because i believe
todd's innocent he was wrongly convicted
so we're trying to fight for his
innocence and
hopefully get him released from prison
he testified at the trial and in his
recent sentencing where he sentenced to
life in prison he also again
maintained his innocence
todd did you ambush
your wife amy in that shed that day and
brutally beat her and chop
chop her up with that corn fork no i did
not
tracy one of the big issues is whether
he he was in a
shed with his son his wife was found
dead
about a hundred yards away from where he
was
you maintain you couldn't have done that
without being noticed by his son who
testified he never
was away from his father that long
correct todd and tristan his son were
working in the
pig pig barn and amy had left to get
something out of a red shed that was
quite a distance away as you saw on the
diagram
uh tristan saw his mom walk towards the
shed
to retrieve the item and todd
was still in the pig barn with tristan
working
todd could not have reached
the red shed where amy was found
in the amount of time it took for her to
die
so it just is scientifically impossible
as you know prosecutors said well the
son did testify that his father was away
from a short time
uh opening the possibility he he could
have done it tracy a question for you
from rhonda schwartz rhonda
i've been following the facebook group
and these are very in-depth postings
people seem to be studying the evidence
tell us a little bit more about the
effort that's going into this and
and the people on the facebook page
i'm really impressed with everyone
that's joined the group so far
um some real in-depth questions
and um members wanting to actually go to
the farm and do their own
testing and see how long it would take
to get from
point a to point b um just a lot of
real good insight and things that
frankly his defense lawyer should have
done to begin with that
we did not see in the trial so we're
trying to do everything we can
to um to show everyone that he is
innocent and to hopefully someday get
him released from prison
tracy as you know on the last day of the
evidence being presented there was a
surprise
prosecutors heard from the tipster that
if they heard the 9-1-1 call that todd
made about his wife's injury
you and he was giving her cpr you could
hear him under his breath muttering some
words about
you should die let's listen to that clip
and tell me what you hear
the tipster said he could hear him
saying
cheating whore
and a few seconds later go to hell
cheating whore
tracy could you hear that no
brian um i did not hear that i heard him
todd counting doing cpr i heard four
i heard she's cold and
that's the consensus in the group as
well that he was counting
and he was out of breath and breathing
heavy from performing cpr on amy
but no we do not hear cheating whore or
go to hell
one of the issues his lawyer raised
unsuccessfully and trying to
get a new trial was that this was wrong
for the prosecutors to present this at
the very last minute
as they did what do you think about that
do you think that's an issue that's
going to become
important i believe it is yes
um when someone tells you what they hear
in a recording
like the prosecution did with the jury
sometimes the power of
suggestion is greater than what is
really there
and once the jury maybe heard
cheating whore that's what they were
then listening for
um so maybe they heard that but without
her
bringing that into the trial and telling
the jury that's what he said
i think it would have been a a more fair
um
tape and a better for the jury to hear
without that
suggestion because then that could
possibly be what they're looking for
as you know todd moses is now serving
life in prison without the possibility
of parole
have you had any further contact with
him and how do you think he's doing
behind bars
um we haven't had much contact several
of our members of the group have
written to todd not much communication
since he got to prison and got his life
sentence
um but we continue to write um try to
keep his spirits up
he's got to be really struggling i'm you
know i know he misses his children
um so whether he responds or not we will
continue to write to him and hopefully
keep him
upbeat and positive
and finally why do you think there are
so many people attracted to this
facebook page and to add to his case
i think people can see when someone's
wrongly convicted
um which we believe todd is and he's
innocent
uh the evidence shows that plainly
and when we see that someone is fighting
for their life and has been wrongly
convicted it's
only the right thing to do is try to
help that person
so you're going to keep going are you
still optimistic you can turn this
around
i believe so yes i the corny saying the
truth will come out
i do believe that and i think someday
todd miles will be free
all right tracy the ritter of the
facebook page todd mose is innocent
thank you so much for being with us and
our report on this killer case on the a
network on thursday night at 10 o'clock
tracy thanks for being here
coming up next this week's winners and
losers in the media
controversy at the white house in the
press room the honeymoon is over
you're watching brian ross investigates
on the law and crime trial network
time now for this week winners and
losers in the media as chosen by the
editors of mediaite
and we're joined by aidan mclaughlin who
is the editor-in-chief of mediaite which
like the law and crime trial network
is part of the dan abrams media company
and aiden winners and losers all wrapped
up today in the controversy
at the white house give us an infill on
what's going on
that's right so tj ducklow who is the
deputy was the deputy white house press
secretary i should say
uh just resigned on saturday night uh
now he had been placed on a one-week
leave
from the white house after it was
reported by vanity fair
that he had called up a politico
reporter and made
threats to her he said apparently on the
call he said i will destroy you
if you report the story that she was
looking into uh and he also made some
sort of derogatory uh misogynistic
comments on the call according to this
vanity fair report
now to just give you a little background
on what uh the reporter
that he called up was reporting on to
cause this sort of furious call
uh the reporter who's tara palmeri of
politico
was looking into his relationship with
another reporter alexie mccammond
of axios and they had been dating alexi
mccammond actually was
covering a dividing campaign in the
biden white house so there was a little
bit of a conflict there
between this communications professional
and the reporter covering the white
house
that he was serving in um so on
inauguration day
tj ducklow calls up tara paul mary and
threatens her and says you know if you
report on
my relationship i will destroy you uh
and he made some other sort of sexist
comments to her about her uh
personal life which were really over the
line that was an off the record
conversation
between uh the deputy press secretary uh
and tara palmeri the reporter but it
eventually leaked out to vanity fair
some weeks later
when it was reported by vanity fair uh
after that
jen pasaki the press secretary in the
biden white house got questioned about
it at a press briefing
she said that ducklow was being placed
on a one-week leave without pay
and a couple days later it was announced
that he was resigning from the white
house
that was on saturday night
so tara palmeira had a perfectly good
story she was
browbeaten by this guy with some pretty
vile language
and yet after president biden said he
would fire somebody on the spot
for rude to others that didn't happen on
the spot did it
yeah exactly so a bunch of people
brought this up after vanity fair
reported it that joe biden said when he
first got into office
that if he hears anyone disrespecting
someone in his white house that they
would be fired on the spot
now i think the the real sort of
controversy here for the white house
is that the white house knew back uh
right when this call was made which was
on inauguration day on january 20th
because politico editors went to the
white house and said
that this threat was made to one of
their reporters and
the white house apologized they had tj
ducklow apologize to tara palmeri
and they said that she wouldn't have to
deal with him um but they didn't
apparently take any other action um and
from you know all we can
see for what we know from this vanity
fair report this was
very obviously a fireable offense um to
threaten a reporter and say such vile
things to them even on
off in and off the record conversation
um so i think the fact that the biden
administration sort of
glossed over it for a couple weeks and
only fired t.j ducklow or
i shouldn't say fired he resigned only
really pushed him out
uh when vanity fair was reporting this
publicly it was a really
sort of a black eye on the binding
communications team and it's obviously
the first
controversy that they've gone through in
the first couple weeks of the
administration
all right aidan thank you so much for
joining and thanks to all of you for
joining us
we'll see you again next week and thanks
to the team at law and crime for getting
us on the air
and getting us off the air so well
foreign